انهم ينقضون المواثيق امروز
وقت در جان زه الوم عندما نرى في قضيه غزه
نرى ايدي الامريكان
والغربيين
علم ان هؤلاء ليسوا الطرف الذي يريد ان ي
يقيم السلام بل هم الطرف الذي له يد في
اشعال الحرب وكل الجرائم التي ارتكب
ارتكبها الكان الصهيون
جاءت يد من الولايات المتحده ونرى ان كل
قرار واتفاقيه او قرار اصدره اصدرته منظمه
الامم
المتحده نقضته الولايات
المتحده دست تا مرفق به خون الولايات
المتحده يدوها
ملطخه بدماء الفلسط حت به ه عنوان
نمونه خود طرف هست در رابطه المحده التي
هي طرف في هذا العدوان على الشعب
الفلسطيني هي لا تستطيع ان تزعم انها تد
ان تقم
السلام الولايات المتحده يجب ان تعاقب
الكان الصهيوني يجب ان
يعاقب الكان الصهيوني والولايات المتحده
يجب ان
يعاقب اتهام الاباده الجماعيه بسبب
عبادتهم الجماعيه في المحاكم الدوليه
عدالت ح فرماه من اجل ان تقوم العداله وان
تسود
العداله
نق النقطه
المهمه جان هي ان قضيه
غزه كشفت الوجوه على حقيقتها وثبت لعالم
اجمع امر د جنا ان الولا المتحده ترتب
المجازر د نسل وترتب بادات
جماعيه وان المتشدق
بالمز بالقضاء على التمييز العنصري هم
الذين يسببون هذا التمز العنص وهم الذ
يقومون بالبادات
الجماع
ننار مرم امرو
فقدم عن
هذهو الناس ان الولايات المتحده وبكل تشدق
بالدفاع عن حقوق الانسان لن تقيم اي وزن
لهذه القرارات والاتفاقيات وهذه المنظمات
الدوليه المتحدثه
والمتشدقون
و بر همه روشن شد واتضح
للجميع ان الولايات المتحده ليست سببا
لاستقرار وارساء السلام في المنطقه
والعالم لا يوجد مكان في
العالم كانت الولايات المتحده فيه عاملا
لارساء السلام بل كانت دائما مثيره للفتن
والحروب وعراقه
الدماء لا احد يستطيع ان يذكر و مكانا في
العالم كانت فيه الولايات المتحده سببا
للسلام الولايات المتحده احتلت افغانستان
لعقدين من الزمن ودمرت بيوتهم وقتلت
النساء
والاطفال و
قتلت والان نجد في افغانستان 35 طفلا
مشلولا المجازر الامريكيه في العراق في
سوريا وفي كل انحاء المنطقه
نشاهدها وهي ملموسه هذه اليقظه الان نراها
ونلمسها في
العالم وفي
الحقيقه ان ديماء شهداء غزه وفلسطين
الزكيه اظهرت حقائق كثيره للعالم ل يعلم
العالم ماذا يج ام با برقان الونه مجلس
الامني اعلن
عجزه تجاه هذه القضيه وهذا العدوان على
فلسطين المنظمات الدوليه جميعها وقفت
عاجزه عن ايقاف الحرب واعلنت عجزها وراينا
عجز هذه المنظمات الدوليه تجاه هذه القضيه
ويجب على ابناء العالمي جميعا وعلى الشعوب
ان لا تعتمد على هذه المنظمات الدوليه
العاجزه عن ايقاف الحرب وارسا
السلام النقطه الت اريد ان اش اليها في
هذا المؤتمر الذي يجمع كثيرا من المفكرين
والعلماء
هي قضيه الهدنه
ووقف اطلاق النار او وقف العدوان الفوري
على الشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه القضايا
المهمه هو رفع الحصار عن قطاع غزه وفتح
المعابر لوصول شاحنات المساعدات لشعب
الفلط للشعب الفلسطيني
الجبار وفتح صندوق خاص من اجل اعمار
غزه ومنع الترحيل القسري للشعب الفلسطيني
الذي تحاول الولايات المتحده والكيان
الصهيوني
مر بهجا برنس از خونه خودش يحاولون يرحل
الشعب الفلسط ا ذهبون ا ترونهم ان
ذهب ما هذه السياسه وما هذا التلاعب
بالسياسات
في تجاه الشعب الفلسطيني واي قضم للحقوق
هذا من اجل الشعب الفلسط تجاه الشعب
الفلسط من بارها به رسا
انا قلت مرارا لرؤساء العالم في
اجتماعات مختلفه
وفي الاتصالت
الهاتفيه ان الذين يعتقدون بالله والذين
يعتقدون بالضمير
الانساني والذين لا يؤمنون بهذا ويؤمنون
بالتاريخ ويؤمنون بالحكم التاريخي كيف
نريد ان نجيب على التاريخ كيف تريدون ان
تجيب شونه مسخ بوم القف تدون ان تج لنداه
بهانه ب